a small study conducted in China in
March revealed that five recovered
coronavirus patients tested positive
days or even weeks after testing
negative this is also happening for a
growing number of patients in South
Korea as countries look to end lockdowns
these reports are raising questions
among public health experts about faulty
testing whether patients are getting
reinfected and just how long a full
recovery might actually take an early
clinical trial in China tested whether
an HIV juror could help treat Koba 19 it
was unsuccessful but it revealed
interesting findings when the
researchers sampled patients for their
viral load
they found roughly 60% were still
shedding virus at day 28 viral load
refers to the amount of virus a person
is carrying and potentially spreading
the implications of what this means are
still yet to be determined
in the US and other countries the
majority of patients are not tested for
the virus after they recover and the
advice from the CDC is to quarantine for
14 days and until they stop experiencing
symptoms but recovery isn't an on/off
switch
nor is it uniform among people so how
does our body typically defend itself
against an invader the process has
several stages it starts with the
physical barriers there is mucus in the
nose that traps pathogens as well as
tiny hairs in the nose and trachea that
sweep out invaders looking for cells to
infect cells in the nose have a protein
that the new coronavirus can bind to it
uses that as a kind of doorway in
infected cells send out molecular
signals that alert neighboring cells
that they've been infiltrated among the
most important are molecules known as
interference
their job is to interfere with the
virus's ability to spread cells called
phagocytes engulf and chew up infected
ones these cells also produce molecules
known as cytokines that cause swelling
the goal is to rope off an isolate
infected cells in tissue to further
control infection and stand the spread
of the virus that would be finalized
what I would say
initial layers of what we call the
innate response that is it's relatively
fast and it's very resourceful
for most invaders these early defenses
are good enough and we never even notice
but some viruses like influenza and
coronaviruses including the novel one or
stealthier so they can dodge these
defenses and replicate unchecked in the
body for some time when we feel sick
we're feeling the effects of our immune
system fighting the virus with
coronavirus scientists think there is a
very sharp increase in viral load during
the first few days of infection the
higher the viral load the more
infectious someone is the fact that we
don't feel symptoms for days suggests
the virus is very good at getting around
the defenses that the body has to fight
infection that also helps it spread in
the most severe Cove in 19 cases it's
the inflammation that gets out of
control and causes all sorts of other
complications like heart issues and
neurological problems we have a third
layer that is very very powerful
phagocytes that ate up infected cells
carry viral proteins back to the lymph
nodes it's there that another set of
fighters known as b-cells and t-cells
will be called into action they use
those viral remnants as templates to
build a more tailored attack this takes
about a week then those those t-cells
and b-cells are sent back to the site of
infection in this case it could be the
land t-cells learn to very specifically
recognize and kill cells that are
already infected sparing those that
aren't these cells make antibodies that
latch onto the virus and prevent it from
entering new cells if it can enter cells
it can't replicate at first these
antibodies aren't very good but with
time they become better and better for
kovat 19 patients tests can pick up
antibodies starting at about 10 days
after symptoms begin according to recent
research for many viral infections this
is typically good enough to protect us
from getting sick again
as this is going on the amount of virus
in the body starts syllable off how long
this takes depends on a variety of
factors including age gender
pre-existing conditions how severe an
infection was prior immunity in how good
an individual's immune response is some
people might only experience mild
symptoms in fact they might not even
notice them at all we only have somewhat
limited data on the viral load of these
people so it's actually not clear if
these people clear infection more
rapidly or more efficiently or if it's
simply that they clear the virus the
same way the other folks clear the virus
but that they managed to not have this
excessive harmful immune response that
that causes damage down the road so in
some people it looks like a week some
people it looks like several weeks and
then it disappears but after that when
you look carefully at the data what you
see or these data points that we call
blips where they're these small amounts
of virus that become present and then
the next day they're gone and then maybe
three days later they're there again and
for how long that that process persists
I think is unknown more data is needed
to know for sure but dr. shiffer
suspects these tiny viral flare-ups
might be causing some of the positive
tests and patients who previously tested
negative scientists have observed this
kind of behavior in the past with other
infections like influenza but what it
might mean for the novel coronavirus is
still unclear alternatively the positive
tests could be picking up dead fragments
of the virus that are still in the body
some recent data from South Korea so
justice might be going on in some
patients different parts of the body
seem to clear the virus at different
rates in a study of 33 patients spit in
mucus samples were virus free within
five weeks for most patients in stool
samples the virus persisted beyond five
weeks for many viruses like herpes and
chickenpox can lie dormant for months or
even years before becoming active again
scientists have been observed this
phenomenon in corona viruses yet and
think it's unlikely
they're short genetic codes don't have
the bandwidth to produce the proteins
that would help them settle in a human
cell lay dormant and then resurface
scientists think these blips pose little
threat to individual patients because
the viral levels are low and the immune
system is better equipped to fight the
virus off my educated guess based on our
experience with other viruses is that at
the individual level the probability of
transmitting when one is shedding for
brief periods of time at very low viral
loads is very low the problem is is that
it only takes one transmission event to
Reese Park an epidemic that risk will
diminish if scientists can develop a
vaccine or if patients can build up long
lasting immunity which would limit the
ability of the virus to spread to other
people with some viruses like measles
immunity lasts a lifetime with the
corona viruses that cause the common
cold and wanes after a few months
leaving us vulnerable to reinfection we
don't yet have enough data to know how
long our molecular memory for the new
corona virus might last what does that
mean for policies on lockdowns on
quarantines that sort of thing it's a
very difficult question throughout the
world I don't think there will be very
many locations or herd immunity is
relevant yet and so when we get the case
countdown to close to zero in many
cities we're back where we started with
a highly susceptible population a virus
that spreads very easily from person to
person and this spark might be a
traveler coming in from a different city
so the answer is going to come down to
the same things which everyone is
talking about which is very wide
availability of testing and then contact
tracing upon detected early cases
you